[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you so much for tuning in if you
could please hit the Subscribe button it
means so much helps us with algorithms
and guests and just knowing what the
heck you want to listen to so please hit
the Subscribe thumbs up and the bell for
notifications today on the show is Dr
Craig Conover he's a Health and Human
Performance expert in nutrition and
science proven protocols uh he is the
founder of coner Wellness as well as
coner Aesthetics I met Dr Conover a
couple of years ago I've been to
Charleston to his clinic and had the
whole car wash of things there we had
all kinds of different modalities and
IVs and his wife Kelly does all the skin
care so she's quite the skin wizard so
that's where I fell in love with the RF
micro needling and the cool peel that
now I work with the company cartessa
whose machines were used on me so great
great like relationship came from that
but they do such a great job and you
know what he does really well is he's
able to balance sort of the practicality
and the mental side of things with the
biological impact and what the science
says and really it's a matter of trial
and error you know we talked about all
kinds of different modalities like NAD
peptides semaglutide and tripiti stem
cells exosomes PRP you know all the
different things that are out there that
you might be curious about so you know
he has a really cool thing coming to his
practice called the choose your
adventure where you can sign up online
and he can help you with it so at the
end of this episode you'll really get
into like a little example of what it's
like to be one of his patients and get
your choose your adventure based on what
it is that you want to have more of so
please enjoy this episode and let me
know what you think in the comments hey
exciting Announcement by optimizers
Black Friday mega sale is happening now
and will last through the entire month
of November and listen carefully because
this Mega deal is available only for my
listeners with only my code we all know
the importance of sleep when it comes to
our overall well-being and while some
might say you can't buy a good night's
sleep I'm here to tell you that yes you
absolutely can I'm talking about
magnesium breakthrough from bio
optimizers a true GameChanger in the
Quest for a better night's sleep it's a
product I trust because it combines all
seven critical forms of magnesium into
one convenient bottle so keep in mind
that when you supply your body with
these essential magnesium forms your in
for an incredible upgrade magnesium
supports a balanced inflammatory
response promotes healthy restorative
sleep relaxation calmness and a better
stress response bio optimizers Black
Friday mega sale is happening right now
and Lasting through the entire month of
November the biggest discount you can
get and amazing gifts with purchase are
available only on my page by optimizers
docomo tenet checkout choose Health this
Black Friday Friday your well-rested
calmer and healthier self will thank you
remember it's bioptimizers
docomo Danica ten so I met you through
uh Ben Greenfield a couple of years ago
uh it was like a Christmas miracle when
he sent me a message I think it was
literally like on Christmas for some
reason or New Year's Day or something it
was like really like on the day and he
was like oh I think you need to meet
this doctor he's really great there it
started which would have been over
almost two years ago and it was so
refreshing to talk to you because you're
like get things simplified you don't
need to take so much stuff like there's
there's such a mental side of it too
where you can just overdo it mentally
and overwhelm yourself more than
necessary and I was like oh my God thank
you that's like music to my ears because
I've been taking 40 pills a day and
doing seven different protocols a day
and it's just like so so much and so
like I really appreciated that but that
started like a really great partnership
but then really friendship because we
hit on so many other levels uh in our
interests um and our belief system than
we do in just trying to be healthy maybe
maybe a little bit of ground workk like
what led you into the health space and
then even the mindful side of it and I I
want to talk a lot about like actual
science like health and science and
biology but the mindful side because I
don't think they are inseparable
like the the mental connection to the
body and your approach to things as well
as the chemistry the biology and the
actual biological things happening so
what kind of got you into all this I
don't know what got me into it I mean I
knew I always wanted to become a doctor
my dad's a physician my grandfather was
a physician so probably there's
something in my genes certainly my
upbringing that I wanted to combine the
science with helping people so it was
just always something I wanted to do it
was like I it was just a knowing and
then you know as conventionally trained
by the really what we call the
pharmaceutical system right in medical
school which dominates medicine as we
know it um which has its pluses for sure
um there's a time and place for
everything but as I got into more of
these other types of modalities which
we'll talk about you know IV nutrition
to you know hormone replacement to
targeted nutrients peptide therapy on
and on what became really apparent
really quickly um for a very simplified
way of describing it is what we think
about the thing is more important than
the thing you know I mean that applies
to what people eat applies to how they
work out and applies mostly to what goes
on inside their head and you know I just
don't like this whole victim you know
mentality that PE that is so pervasive
now which you know some of it is fueled
by this like genetic testing and here's
your genes and you're screw scude
because you have these genes and you can
only eat a certain way and only work out
a certain way I think that's very
limiting and I just see the tools that
you know we get to work with um help
people understand that really what comes
down to is how what you think about it
you know because if you're very limited
in your thought process meaning I have
this diagnosis or I can't go very far I
can't feel very good then it doesn't
matter what you do and then the reverse
is true when you have the mindset that
anything is possible and let's figure it
out and let's just try it that makes it
possible right then and there so what's
the chain of events like if there was
sort of like a a waterfall uh effect to
how we experience our reality and how we
feel in it how would that go I think so
from my perspective there's which I I
think you'll appreciate there's been a
ton of programming right there's just a
ton of programming that takes place as
we move from you know our childhood to
adulthood to accept in responsibility to
growing and developing um and a lot of
it's not good in terms of it helps
people become more obedient and we have
a lot of organizations and the powers
that be will say you know this are the
jump the Hoops you jump through and this
is kind of your lot in life and then you
do that and then we're going to kind of
tell you how to do the next thing and
even extending to what we see a lot with
gurus on social media making it very
stressful for people being like okay if
you want to be optimize your health you
have to do all these really hard things
all the time and to me that's just
that's very challenging and I want
people to have direct access and
experience I think that's the only way
we learn anything you have to try it
like and so we we think of it and we're
announcing this more of a formal program
in 2024 is like Choose Your Own
Adventure because what I think is
helpful for people is empowering them to
have make Sovereign choices of their
life and it's and it can't be too
serious right it has to be like a
playground and Adventure right because
it's become so serious like life is so
serious and people think if I'm not
doing Cal plunge and sauna and doing all
these peptides and drinking all these
shakes and doing all these
high-intensity workouts and fasting
every other day that I can't get it
right and that is so stressful you know
it can for sure be and and then you know
I'm good at helping Shepherd people and
guide people but ultimately where the
magic happens is when someone has that
kind of wakeup Moment Like This is what
resonates with me and I want to do this
for me even if I don't know but I want
to try it and because that's really the
only way we're going to know I don't
know what's going to work for people I
don't but I I want to give them options
that are safe that they can then
experience and I think that's where it
get really valuable and really exciting
yeah well you you you're you're not
trying to say that this one thing that
works really really well works really
really well for everyone and I think
that's important and wise and humble to
say like it's it's you've got to try it
um so talk more about the the choose
your adventure that you mentioned yeah
so most people come to us usually by
word of mouth right and for what I've
learned is that most people it's an
energy aspect right most people want
more energy in their life and they don't
know how to get it right and they may be
taking prescription medicine feel like
they're eating right whatever that means
discipline in their workout trying to
figure out sleep which is elusive but
they're they're lacking some sort of
Vitality or energy and so we're really
good at helping people find energy
quickly and we do that with certain
tools peptides or certain you know we do
a lot of NAD therapy um all kinds of
things that we can talk more in depth
about but once they see like even if
it's you know 10% more then they start
being of the mindset wow this is
possible and then what comes next which
is really to Choose Your Own Adventure
is I don't know what's next right like
how do I know what's next maybe they
want to work on losing weight or maybe
they want to work on their sleep or
maybe they're training for a race and
what I've learned is and I know you
appreciate this there is no destination
in life right it's always the journey
and it's always there's always going to
be a next right but each of us as
individuals I want to help Empower to be
Sovereign over all of that because I
think that's where it's at I don't want
people to feel like you have to do this
because Society or your doctor or your
trainer or whoever tells you you know
like it it really works when it clicks
for people like this is what I want to
try because you can't get it wrong right
like even if you make a bad choice or
you go Direction you shouldn't be going
you just course correct and in life is
just one choice after another it's never
over so you can never get it wrong
exactly and even if we take it and
really distill it down even to because I
know people are hung up on a lot of ways
people I see are lab results and we
really look at that and say even all
that's made up right all of these
reference ranges that we use you know we
do a lot of hormone replacement with men
who are using testosterone those
reference ranges are all made up right
and then people often ask using that as
an example I mean I spoke to a patient
yesterday and he was like where should
my testosterone be and this was a former
NHL player hall of fame hockey player
and he's like I'm not feeling good we
did lab work we saw where his levels
were and he's like what should I aspire
to be and I said I don't know like I
just want to see how you do you you meet
the guidelines for testosterone let's
start you and then we'll figure it out
so men do better at 800 some men do
better at 1200 some men do better at 250
I don't know what that answer is yeah
all unique I mean one of the classic
ones that I feel like is getting more
and more conversation about kind of how
[__] sh it is is like cholesterol
like a simple one yeah cholesterol is
not just just the number it's more
complicated than that and you know lo
and behold the most healthy foods have
the highest CH cholesterol so like right
well even taking a step further we have
a generation of adults who are on you
know cholesterol lowering medication at
this point and we really haven't made a
dent in the you know mean it's about
money statistics about lowering you know
heart disease and decreasing heart
attacks
cancer either I mean it's it's abundant
who invented these ranges and like I'm
just being suspicious and curious of
like you know was the cholesterol number
when did that get established and was
that established by you know those who
are trying to feed us all the grains and
things like that like don't eat your
steak and eggs man it's going to make
your cholesterol go up and they're like
if you put this range over here would
really help us sell more bread and a
little less eggs yeah no I mean so I
remember when I when I was in medical
school in the late 1990s they talked
about this is the big like Staten boom
this is when it all all these you know
ranges came out and I remember when I
learned that the doctors who formulated
these reference ranges all sat on the
boards of the pharmaceutical companies
that was like an aha moment and it's and
again I listen I think there's lots of
ways to do it but what I certainly
learned through coid is which I think a
lot of people appreciate
these pharmaceutical companies are not
telling us the whole side of the story
right there's so many you know negative
drug studies which means they didn't
meet their goals or it didn't work out
the way they wanted those are never
published and so then we'd only know
maybe half of the story and so again I'm
not discounting Pharmaceuticals there's
a time and a place yeah yeah I mean I
don't want you to like wave lavender
over my face if I just got in a
traumatic car crash sure and I think I
think there's people who benefit from
cholesterol lowering medication but I
think to your point that you said is it
can't be as linear as that otherwise we
would have put a huge dent in the
frequency and the rate that people are
getting heart attacks and statistically
we really haven't so then you have to
ask well there's more to it right
there's a lot what has gotten better has
anything gotten better like is there
like what are the biggest issues like
what has gotten better start there I I
think from a chronic disease point of
view it's all getting worse there's more
cancer there's more more heart disease I
mean I read recently there's more
autoimmune disease than cancer and heart
disease combined these are massive
numbers right and so it doesn't seem
like from a societal point of view that
we're moving in the right direction at
all what is an autoimmune disease by the
way yeah so autoimmune disease would be
get your immune system basically
attacking itself right so part of the
people are familiar with their immune
system like if we get bugs in our system
pathogens bacteria viruses parasites
that your immune system goes on you know
like a Army attack and attacks it but
another job of our immune system is
their cellular turnover at certain rates
right certain cells turn over at a
certain rate so part of the job of the
immune system is to pick up you know
dead tissue versus vit vital tissue in
an autoimmune instance it's attacking
vital tissue that's a living tissue why
would your body do that it messes up you
know the immune system is very
complicated just a mistake or like a
misdirection yeah so a great example a
common one would be Hashimoto
which is autoimmune thyroid disease
where you are attacking you know people
with hachim Modas are attacking a
specific thyroid enzyme that Cleaves an
iodine off T4 to make T3 and if you let
that linger long enough you'll become
hypothyroid and you know slow down like
you're living in quicksand and so that
tends to happen based on again this is
just general is your immune system
instead of making an antibody to a virus
right it makes an that an antibody to
that enzyme same thing with food gluten
is a common example with Hashimoto
instead of making antibodies to a
specific food or virus it's making
antibodies to specific things related to
the thyroid yeah and there's the
different many different expressions of
an autoimmune sort of disease tons tons
of autoimmune disease from celiac
disease to type 1 diabetes to Ms Right
to lupus rheumatoid arthritis shog you
know
Scleroderma all kinds what are you
seeing in your clinic or practice or
just even in observation with The Arc
that we've taken over the last few years
and like the Fallout now with coid and
the vaccines and like what's the what's
the pathway that it was affecting and
then is the Sol do we like what was the
vaccine doing did it help and does it
help does it hurt like I hear so many
scary things about it that I mean I'm
I'm going by what everyone else is you
know I can tell you personally seeing a
lot of vaccine injuries that that's very
real right that that is very real um
from data that's been published that's
been made available it seems to suggest
very strongly that the more vaccines
people get the more susceptible they are
actually to co so I think the great
experiment saying we're give people
vaccinate all these people and then
we're going to lead to a decrease
increase in coid which is the whole goal
didn't play out to be true and as a
result more people are getting coid but
they're also suffering from lots of side
effects of something that was untested
you why is it affecting the heart so
much it seems like that's one thing that
you see a lot of heart issues and heart
attacks and sudden death is now a cause
of death it is and I it seems to be in
in the male population more than the
female population really young men you
know so it may be that there's some
underlying issue with their heart that's
being a source that's attack you know
the immune system again is is not in
very simple terms handling the
overwhelming you know immune response
that the vaccine is you know triggering
I don't know why specifically the heart
I mean but I've seen things with the
heart people have had Strokes a lot of
autoimmune stuff lots of autoimmune
things have come up and then we're also
seeing a lot of what they're calling
turbo cancer um where people are getting
very aggressive cancer
um which is you know again that happens
but it seems like it's happening at oh
because your immune system is is been
compromised screwed up yeah yeah like it
can't fight
anything or doesn't have as much
bandwidth maybe or inflammation it's
just it's just a lot you know it's
overwhelming it's like an overwhelming
assault so the trouble is is I think if
we were reasonable and rational we'd be
able to have these conversations openly
and say hey I know you have to watch
your fe's and q's I'm sure for sure you
just have let's take a step back and
let's say okay we tried this and I
understand why we tried it my big thing
is I just don't feel like these things
should be mandated you know I mean I
think people need to have choices always
have choices and be able to make
informed decisions at the time when the
vaccines were introduced there's a lot
of fear um and that fear persists but I
I don't I don't I think it's a very
slippery slope when everyone's you know
they say take care of the collective
good over the good of the individual I
don't think that's ever played out well
history yeah it's like the whole joke of
like if I put on a um if I put on a uh
life preserver vest then you're safe
right when we jump in the water what
yeah same thing with like sunscreen like
if I put you know you to put sunscreen
on so that I'm
protected and that it just you know
again people want to choose that all day
long I I love Yeah but everything should
be available absolutely and if you don't
want to choose that then that's your
choice yeah well you know you me fear
and I think that kind of Loops us back
around to the mind and how like our
orientation around everything and you
know specific to that like and what we
were just talking about like I don't
watch the news if I was watching a
sports event like some some sport some
sport on TV and then news came on right
after and I saw and you know here in the
valley we're having an an outburst of
and i' would be like click off like I
don't want the programming I don't want
it in my psyche I don't want to know
know and you know I I just my experience
like I had a very I had a very good like
Pleasant safe experience I didn't never
have it I didn't get sick I didn't you
know there was just like you know you
know thank thank God but I can't help
but keep them sort of connected the two
of being really not like in the mindset
of it and not in the fear
programming and and understanding that
there are real experiences that we can
have as people and and and we can all
get sick but um but it didn't become
part of my experience and I feel like
maybe some of it was because I didn't
put it into my into my mind and my
psyche and my programming I'm sure I'm
sure you know but I but but contrary to
that I can say I kind of live like you
live in that regard with the news and
stuff and I got Co really badly like
sickest I've ever been August of 21 like
horribly sick and still Wonder like what
happened there like 3 weeks of so so
sick so it's it's it happens I mean
maybe I mean I mean I know you
appreciate it's all about vibration and
energy anyway so it's just being on that
certain vibrational frequency um yeah
yeah again that can happen but we can
either have a state of fear and anxiety
and discomfort all the time and get sick
or we can be good good good good good
good sick good good good good good good
right just not put that fear into your
mind and just go this is just happening
it's an experience in life and you know
[__] happens it's true and I mean if you
really wanted to Ste it down life
happens only moment to moment like there
you can't live in the future nor can you
live in the past even though our brains
have a hard time with that and that's a
huge problem with social media is like
okay learning about all these bad things
that are happening around the world to
people like what good does that do
people say oh I need to know for what
like what does it what does it do to you
it's going to make you anxious and
scared and the more you play into that
the more you will attract that that's
very real yeah man it I sometimes go
through this in my mind this
contemplation
between like knowing being aware and
trying to do something about it
versus if it's more important to just
live the best life I can in the happiest
state that I can be in and be the living
example instead of trying to um be an
activist in any kind of way it's like
not in me to be an activist but even
just even becoming aware of it to kind
of be able to speak to it it's uh I get
really conflicted because it kind of
makes me feel like a dick that I don't
always know what's going on but I also
am protecting my own energy and trying
to just say like look if I just live my
best life then it will the frequency
will help and also it will be an example
for how like a state of mind to maybe be
in have you ever thought about that
before for sure but I would I I think
yeah and so I think if if all of us here
on this Earth just focused on our own
self and being an example what a
different world we live in but even
using that as an example I think what
people do when they become you know want
to you know be active for a cause
they're still motivated by fear and this
is the problem if you want to help if
anyone wants to help you're helping
because you want to do some good and
where you need to be really Sovereign
over it versus I want to help because
I'm scared and I'm bringing that
negative energy to it because I would
argue that a lot of these Collective you
know whatever you want to call them
coalitions or organizations to bring
light to something is rooted in fear and
negativity so then you're spreading that
beer and negativity on a massive scale
yeah as opposed to the intention is no
I'm just going to do this because I want
to because it feels good to me it's the
intention of that positivity you don't
bring the fear and scarcity to it I
think that's what most people do because
of the programming you know when you
think about people like um gurus of
sorts or people like teachers spiritual
teachers they don't really actually
speak to directly about issues much
right they're more like here's the way
to think about things here's how to live
they're not they're not sort of picking
aside or or letting people know careful
of this and help these people here it's
like they're really just speaking to the
mindset to a way to live to how to think
you know how to be ways to be um are not
really speaking exactly to it and these
would be the people that we would think
are sort of the most peaceful
enlightened happy people and if everyone
was like them then the world would be a
different place and by example they're
actually not really activists they're
like activists for the for the self and
soul and mind for sovereignty I think
that's a great example right and you
could even extend it as far as like
because people I see you know beat
themselves over the over the food they
eat and having a glass of wine and I say
to them like why would you ever do
something you considered bad to yourself
like think about that like why would you
ever drink wine and then be like I am a
bad person I just put alcohol in my body
like that process is what's bad you have
GL right like it's like having a glass
of wine and and furthermore you have to
come to terms with like you're in charge
of you like if you want to have the
glass of wine all day long and if you
also want to have six glasses of wine
and feel horrible the next day you need
to own that too you know what I mean
that's where the sovereignty comes in
like and it's all good it can't be bad
but it is bad when you're sitting there
beating yourself up and feeling guilty
over something that's made up like
people like oh I need to eat all this
kale well do you I don't I don't know if
you do like and people go crazy over
nutrition like it's me versus carnivore
versus paleo gluten-free like the only
way to know is to try that's so right
the negativity of it you know there's
one thing I've learned over the last few
years and you've been along for for the
ride like it you really do have to just
try things for yourself it sounds so
lame it doesn't sound like an answer
we're meaning making machines we'd love
to just have the magic formula the right
diet the right workout the right fasting
protocol the right whatever but it's
really like how your body works and I
think a lot of that has to do with one
how your body works but then number two
what just feels good to you because then
you don't stress out as much like you
know for me like I just don't do well
fasting so like that stressed me out a
lot like I'm like how many goddamn hours
am I up to I have three more to go oh my
God like and you can't break it with
like one damn calorie and I'm like oh my
God but so I mean go ahead I feel like
you have some feeling
yeah well I mean I don't do well with
fasting either right and I I think what
it's all about is if we take it a step
further and say well how do you know
fasting is good for you like all these
people are listening to these podcasts
and they're saying here's how you're
going to be healthy and here's how
you're going to Insurance how do you
know like if it if you don't try it then
then it may not be good for you the only
way to know is through direct experience
that's the only solution like you can
read all you want St on the sidelines
and say okay I know I think fasting is
good till you try it how do you know and
then you got honest with yourself and
say be genuine like I it's not for me
and that's awesome like that's great
you're not doing anything wrong what
you're doing wrong in my opinion only is
by making the decisions based on fear so
what what do you find the most common
things that like men come in for and
what Comm what are the most common
things that women are looking for I
think if the unification that would be
energy like I alluded to men it takes
them longer to want to do something
about it men tend to wait and wait and
wait and think they can fix it
themselves
women tend to be you know want to talk
about it more and explore it more and um
are more open to you know I think
possibilities men will get there but it
seems to be there needs to be more of an
urgent need that Something's Happened
you know it used to be that we would
joke that we wouldn't see men unless
their arm was falling off right like men
would just wait until there's severe
pain to want to work on something I
don't think it's that bad but it's in
line with that whereas women are like
open to like oh yeah I read about this I
want to try this I learned about men are
like they'll get to it eventually so
what are the best things for energy then
what and like what also zaps it the most
like what are the most energy sucking
things that you commonly see and then
commonly what are the best best
protocols to increasing energy I mean I
think that the number one would be our
phones right and living in like this
artificial light and people being away
from natural light um I think most
people would tell you you know they
don't eat a clean diet or they don't
work out enough but I I would think it's
these digital devices and living on
social media and living on our phones
and that stress and that Collective
stress of feeling like you have to keep
up always and that vicious cycle that
takes over and then you have trouble
sleeping and then you don't get good
sleep quality and then you caffeinate
and then you're drinking coffee all day
and then you still haven't gone outside
and it's just I think the light aspect
is really important that um you know
light itself is probably the most
important nutrient we can get um and I
and I tell people you know when people
are really sick you know that there's
really a very straightforward fix for
most people is just go live in nature
for a while put leave your phone right
and get back to the rhythms of the
sunrising the sun setting the Earth all
of that I mean that's what people did in
primitive times Vision quests yeah and
like or even just you know the simp
simplification of it right we're all
addicted to our phones I'm not saying do
away with the phones do away with
digital stuff and all that it's all
important but just recognizing that
probably people are worn out tired
stressed out which then plays into their
Physical Realm starts there yeah yeah
yeah well especially when we know that
phones have been developed by like those
people who built casinos and taught like
learned how to get you addicted to
something just understand that you're in
Vagas every damn day of your life
because that's that's who's designing
everything to try and keep us hooked and
give us more to keep hitting the
dopamine button so that we keep coming
back and you know anybody who's been to
Vegas or a casino goes oh that sounds
that would be a lot it's it is a lot
right I mean it's it's a tremendous lot
so you ask what can people do we have
really good success with using you know
things like NAD therapy which is that
vitamin B3 D let's talk about that for a
minute because that's actually one of
the first things I did with you I feel
like was a loading dose of NAD and you
know to to to share my experience um uh
which is doing it five times in 10 days
depending on what your schedule is just
five times in 10 days and so it took it
can take up to four or five hours if you
really can't take the medicine very
quickly because it does make you feel
pretty shitty mean you feel kind of
oddly nauseous in a way you feel like
histamine reaction like you get a stuffy
nose and you know it's just a very weird
feeling um and you don't feel great um
so it took me quite a while most of the
time I mean it took me I don't think I
did it any quicker than 3 or 4 hours
three three three and a half and I felt
like each one got a little bit easier I
think like even to the point where maybe
I didn't keep it up I know that's the
loading dose and then you do it once a
month after but um but I feel like I did
it once or twice after and I and I was
able to do it without Zofran like I
didn't feel sick and so you know explain
why I would have the experience that I
did and um you know you're kind of one
of those pioneers of NAD and have really
made it much more popular here so and
you've shared it with a lot of your a
lot of your patients do it and it's um
it's a really popular treatment yeah I
mean and so the basics it's a vitamin B3
derivative or a chemical cousin of niin
and it's used in many ways but what it's
known for is being the stuff or the
substrate are mitochondria the batteries
of the cell cells use to take fuel that
we eat you know fats carbohydrates and
protein and convert it to chemical
energy called ATP and NAD is one of the
important you know parts of that process
and so what we've learned you know with
academic research over the last five to
10 years is a lot of the health of
individuals the cells um even you know
getting into chronic disease from
diabetes heart disease cancer neuren
disease goes back to the fate of those
mitochondria and so we're fortunate that
we've been working with NAD longer than
most people we found that using it
intravenously for the bioavailability of
it because Ned is not absorbed well
orally you can still absorb a little but
you get most out of it intravenously
leads to literally transformational
results for most people not everyone and
not everyone has a need one of the holes
in this arena is we don't have proper
lab testing to say oh here's your NAD
status here's where you need to get we
don't have that so we've learned just by
trial and error with you know
anecdotally with patients and seeing how
patients respond we've been doing it a
long time that people do best with the
loading dose like you did and then from
there most people want to continue it
you know about once a month um and it
leads to you know most people say their
mood is better colors look brighter
languaging is easier sleep is you know
more compact they get more restorative
sleep so they have more energy um
physically they can recover from
workouts more they feel like they're
more creative all these popular things
and and really positive things it does
it's like cellular Fitness this I tell
people it's like working out your cells
so like you would do a really
challenging workout and you'd be huffing
and puffing in short of breath same
thing with NAD because you're cleaning
up the debris so to speak so for most
people it's really impactful not
everybody um but I like people to try it
like we've been talking about um and you
know we're really biased about it
because we've overseen probably more
treatments than anywhere else and we see
the impact it makes on people yeah it's
and it's for most people amazing it
might be interesting to do again I had
such like a constell of problems and
probably with the giant cloud of
implants over the top of it um just body
being in kind of like an inflammation
mode all the time um so I didn't notice
a ton other than the fact that it didn't
feel great and you did say that that can
be a sign of there being more cell like
you know unhealthy cell death and you
know it can it can kind of be an
indication of your state yeah it seems
that the harder it is for people the
more they need it yeah I like people to
try it and but again some people it's
just not their thing and that's fine too
that's great yeah what about um peptides
peptid something I did too um for quite
a few months um again I I again I had
such a constellational problems I'm just
not really sure if I can be super clear
about how I felt about it I feel like my
body is in a much better State now that
if I tried things it's kind of just like
if you just throw you know if you throw
a glass of water on a bonfire like right
it's not going to make a difference you
know what I mean and like if these
things were so
Monumental it would be no question
everyone would do them so they're really
like always assisting right there's the
sisters and sometimes they make a little
bit of a bigger difference for someone
else but like you said if if it helps
you 10% that would be a great effect and
so you know I think some of these things
were a little bit of a struggle because
of where I was at but I did try peptides
and I'm and i' I'd be open to try them
again but
um what's what's going on with peptides
these days yeah so to back up a little
bit peptides are just chains of amino
acids we considered a peptide if it's 40
amino acids or less considered a protein
if it's 41 amino acids or more so by
Nature these are small molecules by and
large most of them are injected
subcutaneously Under the Skin and we
started many years ago with these
Fitness peptides growth hormone
releasing peptides that help the
individual put out more growth hormone
growth hormones and anabolic hormones
helps you men rejuvenate helps your
tissue repair um but since that time
blossomed into peptides for inflammation
peptides for your immune system peptides
for your nervous system peptides for
your mitochondria you can even give
yourself a suntan with peptides right SK
tanning for sure melanotan yeah
absolutely and so we found over time
that combining the peptides into you
know unique kind of stacks for lack of a
better term really help people because
we can use multiple peptides at the same
time and just works out really well how
many peptides are there would you say oh
I don't even I mean thousands
I don't there may be that many but
therapeutically I mean we're using 30 or
less maybe just not a
lot but they they've just they've been
super helpful for people by and large
because they're so safe we don't see
really any negative side effects like at
all so super super safe you ask what's
the status well as of last week the FDA
has reclassified most of the peptides we
use that they're no longer going to be
in use anymore and this comes as a
surprise um but they will no longer be
able to be compounded or made whatsoever
so they've been taken off the market and
so it's it's a surprise really and I
think what happened I mean in all
transparency is you know semi glutide or
OIC and tepati or mouro which are the
they're peptides but for weight loss
have just exploded to become the number
one prescribed drug in America it is H
number one now number one it's huge and
so I think the pharmaceutical company
said wow there's some something to these
peptides so what would their reason be
to take them off the market what would
be if you were to say okay if I'm going
to put my sort of conspiracy hat on
about why they would take them off what
would what why what's going to happen
the the amount of money that's being
made from selling semi glutide and mouro
is massive tritide tritide so if they're
thinking these are peptides and now they
look at the whole Fleet of peptides and
say wow there's a whole
world out there that we could tap into
and make it into a pharmaceutical
wouldn't that be a good thing I mean I
don't know but that's and why
pharmaceutical company exactly yeah and
so then I mean that's I mean again it's
all big profit so then it's taken off
the table and the challenge is
unfortunately and I don't know if most
people realize this when we compound
things we're able to do that at a lesser
cost right so t eptide semaglutide for
most people their insurance is not
covering it's going to cost $1,500 a
month or more right so when you make
these things into Pharmaceuticals
actually the cost goes up access goes
down as the whole people suffer right so
I don't think this is a good thing but
it's you know we have to operate within
the confines of how things are run so of
course we will so can you get any of
these things with a prescription it
would no longer be available any of any
of the peptides there's there's some
peptides that are left um that we'll
still work with and which ones are
left some some esoteric ones but I mean
some some things like there's a
mitochondrial peptide called humanin
which is still allowed to be used but
again all the big like bp157 like CJC
1295 like amorin some of like the big
ones gone thymus and Alpha 1 tb500 mat C
uh kpv cmax sank all taken off all of
them um but you know for most people
that's unfortunate because again from
our Vantage Point such a safe therapy
and people really enjoyed the benefits
right there's no Silver Bullet to this
but it's it was really assisting in some
big ways but that's I mean that seems to
be how we're these things are lining up
right it seems to be there's going to be
more fear more like scarcity right and
then you know you have to fit into this
a circle peg into a square hole and we
know it doesn't work but that's just you
know we're so that's the way we're
moving with everything for better for
work yeah so they're are they off the
market right now are they off so so the
the FDA classifi I think it starts
November 1st but um they will no longer
be able to be compounded so they will be
no compounding pharmacist will be able
to purchase the raw material to make
them they will be gone yeah there's
there's still if people have them can
get them but that's going to change very
within a matter of weeks changes the
whole do semaglutide and tritide fall
underneath that or are they separate
they're separate because they've been
classified as
Pharmaceuticals um so for right now
they're available to be compounded
although what I've heard is that will
probably change too that will proably
people probably lose access to that and
then have to be a you know have to go
through brand name and to be clear the
brand name is in the injector pen it has
nothing to do with the semi glutide or
tpti it's the injector pen which is
where the patent is the material works
just as well even without the injector
pen and it's a lot cheaper but again the
pharmaceutical companies aren't happy
with that who should stock I know things
have to be kept cold like in my peptides
when I got them like you have to keep it
cold is they're like do you want to go
get all you can and can't you like
reconstitute it with liquid like doesn't
it come with as a powder sometimes yeah
I mean there are um places on the
internet which are research companies um
that people can go search and and buy on
their own that still have this stuff for
sure um I don't know how long it's going
to last I can't imagine very long yeah
well it wouldn't do you any good because
you could couldn't go sell it afterwards
anyway right so this would have to be
for for personal use right totally but I
mean it's right which is fine which is
great for people to find it on their own
and do it it's just I I just I think
this is going to be a really hard pill
to swallow people it's they're going to
go away pretty quickly this is a big
declaration by the FDA we already know
we don't love the FDA so there's GNA be
Anarchy like when does that happen like
I feel like we already saw it with this
whole like oh the next pandemic is
coming and people were like a giant no
way I'm following the rules this time
like they were and then it all of a
sudden died out it seems like seemed
like and I and I wonder I mean people
ask me that is like is there a next wave
coming of Co I and then more masks and
more mandates and all this I don't know
I mean to your point it would seem that
people are frustrated and aren't going
to tolerate it but I mean I think we're
g to get keep getting pushed until we
stand up and say you know don't agree
with it and I I don't know we there yet
does that right but I mean this is
folling like this is the peptide stuff
I'm talking about too like when is there
just like s like what does a rebellion
even look like to what seems to be
completely unnecessary it's a great
question I mean but I think that's where
people are starting to wake up into you
know how do these things we do with
government and the greater good fit into
individualism right and what what
crosses the line and where people are
going to stand up and take care of
themselves and their family I mean these
are really important questions I mean
medical sovereignty and sovereignty over
everything though I mean it's just it's
just an extension of it and I think what
we're going to see over the next few
years is you know this is a wakeup time
this is a drudging of it all and it's
all good you know it's all going to be
really good because we're going to have
to ask difficult questions which are
really important for us to ask we don't
it's not serving us living in fear and
scarcity we let the powers to be take
control we don't have Choice anymore
like to the point where there's no cars
like you you get a ride everywhere and
you you you don't own anything and you
love it like they're telling telling you
like from a a a governing standpoint
from a power over you standpoint they're
like you won't own anything and you'll
be happy as ever as happy as you can be
about it like you won't own your car you
won't own your house you won't own your
couches like you won't own anything and
you won't own your own decisions then
probably either and we're headed for
like a very controlled robotic reality
as opposed to this in the magic mystical
experience of life where you're you're
Cho your adventure like thank God you're
starting a program called choose your
adventure to just even like put that
program into people's heads like oh wow
I can great I think the way things are
trending with government and Society is
very disempowering and they're taking
away choices and even on the health
front like you will have mandates likely
okay you get cancer you have to do
chemotherapy right or you have to do
certain therapies or you get a certain
right and I know people will say well of
course you do it's that's in the greater
good it's not none of that you you can't
can't apply those Collective lens to
individuals right it it doesn't work out
like we ultimately all have to make the
choices that we want to make as
individuals and then if we do that with
really good intentions we can come
together as society and recreate
something that's really positive and
Sovereign for individuals that's very
moral and ethical right but it is such a
slippery slope when when you remove
those choices like all the morality goes
out of the picture in my opinion it
becomes completely unethical for people
like you have to do something no one's
Sovereign over any of us right we're
only Sovereign over ourselves so yeah I
think we're headed to potentially a very
tumultuous time when we're there it's
just how bad does it get I did hear when
all this stuff was happening starting in
2020 that it would be about four or five
years yeah um another area that seems
like it's had a lot of rules and
regulations that might be going the
other direction slightly is the sort of
Realm of stem
cells and then like if we kind of
encapsulate some of the other things
from the the bottom up or the simpler
simpler to the more complicated like PRP
exosome stem cells so like what's been
your experience with it do you play with
that do you what you what are your
thoughts about that whole sort of
Trifecta of healing mechanisms I mean
I'm not so sure it's headed in the best
Direction I mean I can tell you that a
lot of stem cell companies during coid
were knocked out of business you know
and so it's the the number because the
stem cells are bad now yeah I mean again
it comes down to how the FDA allows
these the classifications so you know
for example if it's considered a
biologic it's going to be taken off the
table right and there's certain rules
this is why people leave this country to
go do stem cell therapy outside the
country I
did same harsh you know um rules and
regulations applied um and again we're
not saying make it Anarchy but to me
like people should be allowed to try
things as long as we deem it safe as
long as you have informed consent like
that's really important for people to be
able to try different therapies you know
and and when you remove that from go I
don't think that's a good thing right
and I think that that yeah I mean I
think PRP is fine exosome stem cells
though we're talking really about
umbilical cord stem cells umbilical cord
exosomes which is all based on science
does it always work no of course not but
I think that it's very very very safe
for people to try so people looking for
ways you know I I'm going to see a
patient tomorrow who's his knee is
bother me tours MCL and he doesn't want
to have surgery you know and he's in his
late 40s and shouldn't that be his
choice you know that for him to be able
to try other things that work for him as
opposed to being like the only option I
have is to have surgery that doesn't
feel right and that's certainly not
ethical to force his hand so I think a
lot of this stuff needs to sure do we
need more studying of it great you know
but the only way to study it really is
clinically right because you could
research it in a lab all day you want
but until people are trying it and using
it because that's I'm a clinician I'm
interested in people's results you know
until we're doing that we're not really
making progress yeah yeah I used um stem
cells on my dog um she had some knee
issues and so she had some orthoscopic
surgery as well as stem cells and we
harvested stem cells so they took she
took it out of her bone made it right on
the spot reinjected both of her back
knees and then banked it and so she's
already had a stem cell booster about a
month or so ago and like so can you
explain like what they each explain PRP
explain exome stem or the other way
around like however it flows the best
but can you explain what they are yeah
PRP is plet rich plasma so blood is
drawn from your own body from your own
circulation in a special tube spun down
in a centrifuse and so part of that
serum plasma contains these you know
platelet rich they're they're rich of
platelets which then if you inject them
back um they're going to trigger a
healing response and so that's very kind
of basic um if we step up from there I
mean I don't know if stepping up is XM
or stem cells but you know stem cells
are basically um age zero cells that
have potential and the idea is there's
an innate intelligence of the body that
if you receive some of these stem cells
back you can work on repairing things
calming down inflammation you know this
anti-to kindes and really just helping
move the body become you know
rejuvenated younger decreasing
inflammation that's what it's all about
exosomes are similar to stem cells but
they're more like the messenger so a
little bit more concentrated um some
people would say exosomes are better
than stem cells I think they're just
different tools and I think they can be
used in a variety of ways from you know
giving to people in lots of different
vehicles um but again very very safe
like I I've not heard of any you know
bad outcomes from using these tools
certainly you're going to have providers
and doctors who don't know how to use
them right so that would be more of
teaching doctors how to use them but as
a whole the material is very safe what
do you think are the most
helpful or best sort
of again bottom up top down I don't know
timeline wise but like I'm thinking
about for people that want to take their
health more seriously and know more do
more let's call it even like people like
people that you deal with people that
want to like high Achievers people that
want excellent they want to live an
excellent life with above normal they
don't want to be in the range right they
want to be they want to optimize
basically so what would be the right
thing for them to do on like a daily
weekly monthly quarterly yearly basis
like how maybe even how do you do your
how do you do it or how do how would
someone that wants to like get the most
out of themselves and have the you know
have the most energy muscle lean muscle
like be healthy BMI um best skin like
what would be the right thing to do for
them I I think there's there's there's
many paths to the Mountaintop right and
there's Infinity paths and I think the
first thing for people to realize is I
mean life's about trade-offs so if you
really want to be super lean and fit
well then you're probably going to have
to be more disciplined with figuring out
what you shouldn't shouldn't eat how you
work out right and how you sleep and all
these different things there's lots of
tools that we can get into from peptides
diabetes to biodental hormones that will
likely assist you but until you're ready
to be your own experiment then how do
you know and then and then you really
have to be honest with yourself you know
what I mean because fasting may work for
somebody and then eating carnivore all
day long may work for someone else both
are equally good like there's not
there's no judgment and so I think the
biggest thing for people is realize what
do they want next and knowing and and
really sitting with because this is
where I think it's really important that
anything is possible the limiting factor
is your own beliefs right if you believe
that you can't run that Marathon then of
course you can't run it if you if you
think you can't be super lean with a
body of half percentage less than 10% of
course you can't right and so really
sitting with that and understanding that
again like we talked about at the
beginning what you think about the thing
is more important than the thing my
favorite quote Henry Ford whether you
think you can or you think you can't
you're right right and so knowing that
just because you read it where someone
tells you like okay you should be
fasting until you try it how do you know
and so then once you can start down that
mindset of just practicing having open
beliefs and that anything is possible
then there's going to be some baby steps
and really it's the way I think about is
just dialing it in there's lots of
different dials from nutrition to
Fitness to sleep to energy to your mood
to spir spiritual practices to
meditation there's no one right way you
know people will tell you order to
meditate you have to sit for 30 to 60
minutes and have no thoughts and be
really silent like well most people then
that disqualifies them but that doesn't
mean they can't figure out how to
meditate or that you have to do a cold
plunge after an infrared SA or it
doesn't count it's like that's not true
either so I think it's just for people
to realize like anything is possible
start really slowly get some small wins
which means you try something it
resonates with you it feels like this is
I'm on a better path and then something
is going to come into your Consciousness
and awareness that you want to work on
right and that's what we call the next
and so then you might want to work on
that and then you may get you may injure
your knee running and so you can't live
your life in a bubble right I get it
that people want to have assurance that
the things they're doing are going to
lead to Long healthy life there is no
assurances right the only thing you can
do is just be in the moment and be
really honest with yourself that you're
listening to yourself and that it
resonates and from there you just go to
the next thing and next thing and next
thing and really pay attention to your
intuition I think that's what it's all
about right because you we're told by
all these people and organizations and
groups like this is the only this is the
way you have to do it I know for me all
of that's made up so the only thing
that's going to work and that's just
what I've observed with patients is if
you're willing to explore on yourself
right get guidance on how to explore it
that things are safe but ultimately if
you're not ready to be your own
experiment there's only you're going to
be limited in far you get period so I
think that's that's for anyone who's
wanting more just be really honest with
yourself that the next step to me is
being open to trying what does that mean
to you right like and I think these
goals of like anti-aging and Longevity
are way too vague like it just doesn't I
don't know what that means e you know
there's no lab test we can say okay okay
you're gonna be good for 20 years from
now no way so more importantly just work
on yourself for today like be your best
self today and then do that again again
and again
well anti-aging telr are a bit of an
indication is that right I mean the
problem with telome you know the idea of
these telr lengthening and that you
people say within our genes if we have
longer telr it it's going to lead to
longer life we don't know though that
you don't have longer telome because
you're living longer life so you know it
doesn't mean that it's causitive it
could just be there as representative
that's the problem with telr it's not an
exact science no way do you believe that
our were like ca to give us a certain
length of life it's like conspiracy
around 120 years and that's how long
you're supposed to live the telr
basically are the informance of that by
as they get shorter your life it's
shorter it's a parallel thing do you
think that we were have we've been
genetically altered that's a good
question I mean I think there's a lot we
don't know like you and I have talked
before but like I'm really interested in
like what an we're taking a hard right
turn right now good like I'm really
interested in like what ancient people
looked at in the sky right and how that
played out in their life and and I think
a lot of it has been um we don't know
for lack of a better term has it been
covered up I don't know but I told you
about that book the Saturn death CTS
which talks about the Saturn Saturn
could have been our original sun and it
was a very different Earth at that time
we're talking a long time ago but they
think if if Saturn was our son the
effect of gravity was completely
different right and because of this
there was not day and night there was no
time there was abundance of food and as
well we had people living longer at much
larger body mass because we didn't have
the effects of gravity and now that
there's a lot of you know conjecture
there but it's super interesting to
think about because you look around the
world there's these massive monuments
from you know pyramids to ston hedge
like something was related to what they
were seeing in the sky and if we don't
understand that and very few people like
know that their body is representative
what's going on in the solar system
anyway right like it's all one energy
that's being recycled very few people
think about like oh what's going on out
there is actually what's going on here
and if we don't know what's going on out
there then how do you really know what's
going on here you don't so again it all
comes back to this thing is made up it's
all made up we just keep making it up to
make us feel better like oh this is the
way it is right now yeah I think the
collective is20 years is about the max
that people are going to get out of life
but that's for many factors most of
which I would think people can't get
beyond that Concept in their mind they
don't believe it they don't believe it
to be true so if you don't believe it to
be true you've immediately you know
nullified it [__] people don't even
believe 120 years is really possible
they're like man I hope I get 80 good
ones out of it right and and a lot of
that is just like you talked about with
you and Co like it wasn't on your radar
you aren't getting it you're not
experiencing it and guess what you
didn't experience it I think that
applies to everything in life you know
people are always like well let's plan
for this you can only plan so much
you know yeah the whole planning thing I
think particularly with CO's gone out
the window there's only so much of your
life that you can plan whether it's
financial planning health planning
whatever it is like just focus on today
and your immediate future and that
should be good enough I want to go back
a little bit to the what's out there is
what's in here for kind of an at the end
here just to talk about some fun stuff I
was on my I was walking the dogs this
morning and you know I think about this
stuff all the time but in various
different ways but as I'm walking by the
trees I'm just like oh they cut that one
down and now it's growing back and it
looks like veins like right like I'm
curious what your thoughts are about
like the nature of our reality and like
what creates it like what are those
perpetuating Curiosities and current
opinions of what this reality is about
what's going
on a great question yeah I mean it it
seems like on many levels it's it's a
simulation I mean right and that um I
think the the confusing part for people
is that what you experience in your
reality really comes from your own lens
of how you perceive it to be like it's
all coming from the inside and so we
create and we're co-creators in that
reality um which is really important and
should be empowering right like it's
it's all amazing I have a firm belief in
God who created all of it and it's a ful
you know kind of Arena to be a part of
and get to play in but it it has to be
something you play in as opposed to
something you're just you know sludging
through and like it sucks because that
whole victim mentality the more you
focus on that of course the more you're
going to get of that so I think
Consciousness is the driver right and I
think as we wake up and individuals
expand their Consciousness about what's
happening in many different Realms
happening at the same time you know time
to me is made up right it's a fictional
thing like time is existing past present
and future all at the same time um and
that feels that resonates with me I
can't explain it beyond that right like
I don't I don't really can't use words
to understand that or describe but it
just feels right to me and so knowing
that I'm a firm believer that I want to
be the the best Steward of what I can be
in this life because that's going to
then you know pass that light out to
others and help others get that same
experience but I think it's yeah I mean
I think it all starts from what we feel
inside and then project that outward are
we scared of AI
then yeah I mean I think that's
something to be yeah very yeah the whole
movement towards like transhumanism and
like making us into cyborgs and
like it doesn't add up and it doesn't
feel right and when you you know
separate the soul from the body it's
just there's something very inherently
you know that doesn't feel good at all
about that I can see that it can be used
just like Pharmaceuticals like there's a
time and a place
you know if you need to answer some
questions quickly or build a website I
mean it can help you tremendously but
they can't kind of guide your intuition
you know that's the thing you talk to a
lot of scientists of sorts whether
astronomers physicists astrophysicists
like when I talk to them it's more about
maybe we aren't supposed to know I think
if we can ask the question we should be
able to know like because that means
that there's there's something around it
like there's an awareness but but maybe
there's just some stuff we're not ever
supposed to know maybe maybe not in this
reality too maybe as we transcend and
become in different dimensional being
different frequency maybe we become
aware of new information but in this one
maybe where we're at we don't know I
like how Alan Watts um described it as a
game of hide-and seek and when we're
born we have amnesia and um we're
supposed to forget it all but on this
quest in life we have moments where we
remember and we're like oh my gosh these
synchronicity moments where you're like
I got
it but then you forget it again right
and so if you see it as a game which I
appreciate is humor this is a game of
hide-and seek and and everything is a
wave form and so you go through periods
again like where you remember and you
like it just clicks and then you'll go
through periods where it's like really
stressful and frustrating you're like I
I don't even know what I'm doing here
and then but if you trust it it will go
back to you'll you'll remember remember
again at some point and I think the more
you do that with my personal experience
is the more you remember actually you
will have more of these kind of wake up
moments more
synchronicities and it accelerates and I
think the more people who you can engage
with that who also are awake in that
realm just we feed off each other and it
gets really I mean this is why it's s
such an exciting time to be alive is
because if you can appreciate like it's
all theater it's all made up and let's
see what happens and let's see how we
can change that for the positivity and
come from a place of abundance as
opposed to buying into the fear and
scarcity so yeah amen yeah all right
well uh good luck with the choose your
adventure is that on your website is
that our webite yeah it's going to be a
program we're going to hopefully
announce probably announce January 2024
we're excited about it because it's just
different it's just you know people can
sign up for whatever they want it's like
a plug-and play like is it where they
modular system yeah totally some people
be like okay I want to do like methylene
blue or come in and do NAD or you can
get it to like a provider in the area
just to do like an I like an IV company
will come to your house and do it
potentially I mean I think also be
people who aren't that far but they just
want to try some things right there'll
be like different regular supplements
they can try like okay you're working on
losing weight here's what we think is a
good starting point and okay so it's a
modular system but it's based on people
choosing what's next for them being in
that playground and making it not as
heavy and serious that a lot of people
are yeah feel like it has to be it
doesn't well you got to give us
something so what's the first thing
you'd give someone for weight loss
what's the first thing you'd you'd
recommend I mean I mean for people the
tepati and semaglutide works so well my
thing is we just want to use it for a
short period of time right so if you
want to
lose most people it's two or three
months okay and I just don't buy into
the fear that is being messaged that oh
you have to be on the rest of your life
that is not true right run into some
health problems the longer on it so we
just have to check in we check in with
people every few weeks make sure they're
still losing weight feeling good and if
they're not then we pull back right it
doesn't yeah so I think that's the
number one thing right now I mean Works
what about for neurological like
something something so a cognitive
enhancer U methyl blue you mentioned is
maybe the best cognitive enhancer like
we use a lot of that both orally
intravenously people do really really
well with methylene blue it's an MAOI
MAOI inhibitor so it keeps like dopamine
and serotonin around a little bit longer
people feel it I mean they feel kind of
the Boost from an alertness mental
cognitive standpoint it's also antiviral
helps with energy helps with a lot of
things what about for healing like if
somebody has surgery or somebody's been
sick or something like that like what
would they do what's the best healer I
mean I was going to tell you certain
peptides like thymus and Alpha 1 and bpc
work really really well but those are
off the market now off the table um so I
mean there's there's time in tested
things like curcumin um which is a
potent anti-inflammatory Botanical herb
you know that's the active ingredient in
turmeric um which can work really really
well um I think that's probably probably
the top of my list there's certain amino
acids like glutamine which is a really
good choice to help with Muscle Recovery
and Recovery things like that okay what
about for like strength and endurance
like um like working
out yeah I mean I think the the the
equation to put on muscle mass and get
strong is not necessarily comp at I
think you have to you know put some
resistance training in you have to
either lift weights or do body weight
training right I think the key part is
people don't eat enough protein right
and they shy away from that you know we
use just what most people use which is
um you know a gram per every body pound
of body weight so if you're 150 pounds
you should need to have 150 grams of
protein every day most people fall very
short with that and then the third
component that would be some anabolic
substance like whether it be peptides
which help put out growth hormone
testosterone you know for that helps so
optimizing those for people kind of is a
third part to that equation so I don't
think it's complicated it's just the
where people fall off is the protein to
boost your immune system probably is
always a Hot Topic especially in the
winter it is I mean there's several
things but I mean like vitamin C is
great and then people knock it and say
it doesn't work I just don't think
people take enough I think you have to
take a good amount of vitamin C to kind
of boost the function of your tea cells
using something like selenium there's a
whole track record in history of using
selenium which is a mineral or element
um some people would say you can prevent
cancer by using enough selenium so
people could look into that but selenium
is wonderful for the thyroid and
wonderful for your immune system as a
whole we used to use the peptide thymus
and Alpha 1 that's out that's a great
immune booster we'll do intervenous
ozone with people um intervenous
glutathione as a push can work really
well so there's there's lots of options
and what about detoxing I think
sometimes people overdo the detoxing you
know approach is generally let's get
people feeling better first yeah I mean
I think it's like I think there's
something to it but I think my my
question always is like what are you
detoxing from like I think you can clean
up a lot by just focusing on positivity
getting you know the positive thoughts
cleaning up your diet whatever that
means exercising more deliberately you
know introspective work right positive
thoughts in your head um I think most
people are toxic it doesn't add up to me
yeah I think they're toxic from their
own self-thinking
sure okay well then that's going to
finish off with one that I think has so
many ways but sleep like what would you
recommend for sleep sleep is so hard
right it's so elusive that I I don't
it's not like I don't think you can beat
it but I think it's more you work with
it right so I would rather people have
lots of tools that they use a lot than
trying to use one thing so we use a lot
of things like glycine ashwagandha
theanine obviously CBD melatonin there
are certain peptides we can still use
like pinealon um trip toan so there's
lots of different things that people can
try um in varrying dosages that can
really help a sleep and I think that's
always better than taking a
pharmaceutical on a regular basis um you
forgot a really you forgot one really
important one which is a freaking
therapist there you go yeah you tell you
you give me one person that doesn't
sleep well that doesn't need some
freaking talk therapy or some EMDR or
something like like if you're mind is
racing and you can't sleep then what is
going on in your mind like I I I I know
I'm kind of putting a stake in the
ground pretty hard on that but people
that don't speak well need to figure out
what the freak is what's going on up in
their head and I think everyone benefits
from talk therapy I mean you got to have
someone you can have a safe place to
just express yourself even if it's just
for that purpose alone like you know I
see particular you ask about difference
between men and women men feel in many
ways that they don't want to rely on
anything you know like even testosterone
like I don't want to rely on that um and
the truth is we all rely on lots of
things all the time so being vulnerable
to that like that's really good like
raise your hand and get help because we
all need it everyone's anxious at some
point in their life everyone's depressed
at some point in their life everyone
struggles uh with different things but
everyone struggles that's a fact so why
not get you know why not get some people
to help you in that effort no one can do
it alone amen yeah cool thanks Doc that
was awesome I appreciate it and I'll be
stocking up on some peptides there you
go yeah thank you for having me it's
always great talking to you yeah you too
you too and and for beautiful Kelly who
is responsible for the Improvement of my
skin for the people that don't know
coming to see you for like what did I
get curcumin methylene blue we did some
we oxygenated my blood we had to do it
old school because my veins were so [__]
back then body was in shutdown mode um
but I went and saw for um the RF micro
needling and then the um the cool peel
and I just like it was the results were
amazing and then you know not long after
you guys saw uh Gabe from cartessa and
said hey we're gonna talk to Gabe about
you and now we have a relationship and
we awesome yeah it's like it's it was so
wonderful and people comment on my skin
all the time so for those who don't know
and want to make their journey to South
Carolina Charleston which you should
want to go to Charleston anyway because
it's the best city
um it's such a cute southern city um but
Kelly does amazing stuff with skin too
does yeah she's a skin wizard for sure
that actually that's exactly I was
thinking about how I would describe her
and I was gonna say literally she is a
skin wizard she is so the the collective
Consciousness like my uh it's reaching
you in South Carolina from Arizona so
she is a skin wizard awesome she
definitely is yeah yeah all right cool
well give her a hug for me I will for
sure well good seeing you thank you so
much thanks everybody for listening to
the pretty intense podcast today I hope
you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the Subscribe
button